let's see if we can simplify this
expression so pause the video and and
have a try at it and then we're going to
do it together
right now all right so when you look at
this it looks like both the numerator
and the denominator they might you might
be able to factor them and maybe they
have some common factors that you can
divide the numerator and the denominator
by
to simplify it so let's first try to
factor the numerator x to the fourth
plus eight x squared plus seven and at
first it might be a little intimidating
because you have an x to the fourth here
it's not a it's not a quadratic it's a
fourth degree polynomial but like any if
you like a lot of quadratics that we've
seen in the past it does seem to have a
pattern for example if this said x
squared plus
plus 8 x plus 7 you'd say oh well this
is pretty straightforward to factor what
two numbers add up to eight and when i
take the product i get seven well
there's only two numbers that where you
take their product and and you get
positive seven that are going to be
positive and and and and you they need
to be positive they're going to add up
to positive 8 and that's 1 and 7. so
this would be x plus 7 times x plus 1.
well if you just think of instead of
thinking in terms of x and x squared if
you just think in terms of x squared and
x to the fourth is going to be the exact
same thing so this thing can be written
as
x squared plus 7
times x squared plus 1.
if you want you could do some type of a
substitution saying
saying that a is equal to x squared in
which case so if you said that a is
equal to x squared then this thing would
become a
squared plus 8a
plus 7 and then you would factor this
into
a plus seven and a plus one and then you
would you would undo the substitution
and that's x squared plus seven and x
squared plus one but hopefully you see
what's going on here this this is this
is the the higher order term and then
this is half the degree of that so it
fits this mold and so you could do a
substitution or you could just recognize
well okay instead of i'm dealing dealing
with x squared i'm dealing with x to the
fourth
all right so that's the numerator now
let's think about
let's think about the denominator
so the denominator both of these terms
are divisible by 3x so let's let's
factor out a 3x so it's 3x times 3x
times if you factor out a 3x here 3
divided by 3 is 1 x to the fifth divided
by x is
x to the fourth
and then if you subtr if you factor out
a 3x here you're just going to get 1.
and so far this doesn't seem too helpful
i don't see an x to the 4th minus 1 or
3x in the numerator but maybe i can
factor this out further x to the 4th
minus 1. and that's because it is a
difference of squares and you might say
wait i i'm always used to recognizing a
difference of squares is something like
a squared minus 1 which you could write
as a plus 1
times a minus 1. well this would be a
squared minus 1 if you say that if you
say that a is equal to
x squared then this would be a squared
minus 1. so let's rewrite all of this
so let's rewrite so this is all going to
be equal to same numerator
so let's do it in green same numerator x
squared plus 7. can't factor that out
anymore
times x squared plus 1 can't factor that
out anymore
all that over
3x but this i can view as a difference
of squares so this is x squared squared
and this is obviously 1 squared so this
is going to be x squared plus 1 times x
squared minus
times x squared minus 1.
now clear to have an x squared in the
numerator x squared minus 1 in the
numerator x squared sorry x squared plus
1 in the numerator x squared plus 1 in
the denominator and so i could cancel
them out and i'm going to be left with
in the numerator x squared
plus 7
over
3 x
times x squared
minus 1.
now this looks pretty simple and we want
to be a little careful because whenever
we do this canceling out we don't want
to make sure we want to make sure that
we restrict the the x's for which the
expression is defined if we want them to
be algebraically equivalent so
this one would this be
this would obviously be undefined if so
x cannot be equal to zero x cannot be
equal to
plus or minus one positive or negative
one would make this expression right
over here equal zero so it cannot be
equal to zero x cannot be equal to i'll
write plus or minus one that would make
this part zero but this right over here
this one
unless we're assuming we're dealing only
with real numbers
this one can't ever equal zero if you're
dealing with real numbers because x
squared is always going to be
non-negative and you're adding it to a
positive value and so this part this
this factor would have never made the
entire thing undefined so we can
actually just factor it out or cancel it
out without worrying much about it and
so this is actually algebraically
equivalent to what we had originally now
we could write these constraints on it
if we want if someone were to ask me
you know for what x is is this
expression not defined well it's clear
it's not defined for x that would make
the denominator equal zero dividing by
zero not defined or if x is plus or
minus one it would make the denominator
equal 0. but that is that comes straight
out of this expression so this
expression and our original expression
are algebraically equivalent now if you
wanted to you could expand the bottom
out a little bit you could multiply it
out if you like
that's equivalent to so x squared plus
seven over three x times x squared is
three x to the third
minus three x so these are all
these are all equivalent expressions and
and we are done